Edgar ever never is here and he's hot
let's do this
[Music]
greetings and salutations River babes
I'm your host Heather I mean Leeanne
Aguilera and this is your Sweetwater
secrets after show for episode 316
chapter 51 big fun aka the Heather's
musical enjoy the ride now this year's
musical episode was fun flashy and once
again filled with all kinds of
questionable dance moves so fun to
celebrate this special event I'll be
bringing you brand new interviews with
the entire cast as they spill so many
behind-the-scenes musical secrets I feel
like the musical as a whole is really
speaking our lives as it's playing out
but first let's quickly recap the main
things that happened in this episode
when our Riverdale ian's weren't singing
with the blue and gold breakdown now
while the rest of our perfect pitch
teens were taking part in heathers the
musical which was creepily sponsored by
the farm this entire musical is just one
big recruitment drive for you isn't it
jugheads quests to take down his mom was
in full effect this week the mission
find and destroyed the drug lab your
plan is a good one Jack with his sweet
singing siren by his side bug head
discovered that Gladys had her gargoyles
steal the old Jones family trailer and
planned to go full on Breaking Bad and
turn his childhood home into a mobile
fizzle rocks Factory drugs terrible when
Betty wasn't off spying on the farms
weird rituals in between rehearsals she
decided to put her new love of fire to
good use and she helped Jughead burn
away Gladys's plan talked about watching
your childhood go up in flames meanwhile
with Evelyn ever never promoted to
co-director she was determined to infuse
the farms culty behavior plus drugs and
alcohol directly into the stars of the
musical that's the spirit but despite
her bizarre directing tactics opening
night of Heather's was a success how do
we know well because the cast final
number got a super creepy slow clap
which was started by none other than
Edgar ever never
my dad would like were you shocked by
the farms eerie standing ovation yeah so
was the cast so take a look at what Lily
cami and Casey had to say about the
farms involvement this week it's
definitely involved and definitely adds
a very strange aspect which it's really
fun and weird and twisted and exciting
we find them kind of dealing with the
mysterious connection between the farm
and Riverdale and what their their
purposes in Riverdale there's something
eerie going on the farm co-producing the
musical is very suspicious to Betty
screams
recruitment she knows that something is
wrong with them they've changed her
mother drastically and her sister and
she just like doesn't quite know what
they are yet but she knows that they're
bad she has this gut feeling
I think the farm co-producing the
musical is scary to her she doesn't want
the farm to dig their claws into other
classmates and into more for friends
it's scary but I think Betty being in
the musical gives her an opportunity to
keep an eye on everything and make sure
that they're not going to entrench where
they shouldn't although they probably
still will I know cheer up - for
Veronica
I think she's dealing with a lot of
family drama and a lot of relationship
drama and it's all kind of crashing down
at once
she's very overwhelmed and kind of
pouring herself into the character of
Heather making Tamara I for one could
use a libation now let's switch away
from the farm confusion and focus on the
cute reunions we had this week and seven
seconds in heaven now we all know that
Hyrum and Hermione Lodge are the most
volatile couple in town but I was still
shocked when they revealed they were
getting a divorce and so was Veronica
wait what is happening now this
home-wrecking news caused V to run right
back into Reggie's perfectly toned arms
and although he questioned her
intentions at first it seems like veggie
is back on our plates for now baby we're
in-game Archie and Josie spent all
episode doing some soul-searching and
singing about their feelings and now
their relationship is officially out in
the open did you know about this why no
I had no idea meanwhile Kevin and fangs
sweet but bizarre smooch and it was
nearly World War three in the halls of
Riverdale after Shoni shocking split the
school is not big enough for both of us
but Tony was determined to figure out
what was really at the root of Cheryl's
terrifying behavior and thanks to her
compassion and persistence show me is
officially back together
how beautiful I'm still not sure why
they broke up in the first place but yay
and lastly while the trailer was going
up in flames
Thanks between Betty and Jughead got
pretty heated as well and here's a fun
treat while we were in between takes
with cami Charles Cole and Lily we asked
these real-life lovebirds to weigh in on
some of the on-screen couples in this
episode and here's what they had to say
Veronica and Reggie's storyline has kind
of been something that's been
established in the comics from a while
back and I think Veronica
post-breakup with Archie she's
vulnerable she's broken she's hurt and I
think she's looking for comfort and
Reggie really seems to be kind of
devoting himself to her he's really
proving himself to be someone who's
there for her someone she can rely on
and I think Veronica sees that in him
and is kind of trying to distract
herself from all the the pain she
experienced with Archie and you know
giving into this relationship with
Reggie I was afraid this was never gonna
happen again me too
Reggie and Veronica are trying to figure
things out right now uncharted territory
I think Betty and Jughead are good they
being solid yeah Betty helps joke it out
quite a bit in this episode jacket
himself is not in the musical he's doing
security for the musical so you know
musicals aren't exactly jugheads vibe
but they're still kind of working
together and they're still very much a
team and it's really nice I'm surviving
because you're here with me and now
let's change our tune to my favorite
part of the episode with hisses and
kisses now I feel like I should preface
all this by saying the majority of all
my hisses this week are on the silly
side so bear with me hisses - Evelyn for
constantly saying the words big fun
throughout the episode last night was
big fun girl no one talks like that I
mean I get that it was the name of the
episode but still to have big fun hisses
to whatever the hell was going on
between fangs and Kevin I don't trust it
they're adorable together
but be careful you guys don't know what
your kids are thinking what they're
dealing with and his sister Tony for
luring sweet Pete and peaches and cream
with the promise of some weird threesome
and then ditching them on stage once
they were only wearing their underwear I
shouldn't have brought you guys here I
can't do this yeah that happened
hisses to Veronica for publicly
advertising that she's looking to hire a
new bouncer did you have a lobotomy for
breakfast hey babe what part of 'secret
speakeasy are you forgetting about I
mean yeah LaVon do we is like the
world's worst kept secret in Riverdale
at this point but putting up a Help
Wanted sign on pops front door is
probably not helping no no no oh and I
have both a hiss and a kiss to the fact
that Tony and Sheryl literally fought
over the color red
you're wearing my signature color red
existed before you I invented red I am
red seriously I was equal parts annoyed
and amused over the scene and who are
the random snap girls behind Cheryl I
think we can all agree on one thing Tony
looked incredible and maybe Red's her
color yeah we got it thanks switching
fully over to kisses kisses to the boys
in this episode looking at you Archie
Kevin and Reggie for their various
moments filled with interesting dance
moves and kisses through the ladies for
the candy shop choreography battle
royale Tony but then also kisses to
Shoney's rekindled romance I especially
liked this sweet smooch and that's my
favorite part
what kisses to Cole Sprouse for finally
gracing us with his voice not bad jug to
Betty for becoming a full-fledged
pyromaniac and to the fact that Hiram
brought his self-portrait with him to
the five seasons
it was both conceited and considerate
how very kisses to the hilarious faces
of all
Riverdale families while they were in
the crowd trying to figure out the final
number
Penelope looked unfazed J BFP and Gladys
were confused as hell and the lodges
were less than enthused it sucks about
your folks Oh in this case it's going
straight to Edgar ever and ever for two
reasons
number one I am so thrilled that we
finally get to see this mysterious cult
leader that we've been hearing about all
season and number two good god he's
attractive fact and lastly I'm sending
mega kisses to the entire Riverdale cast
for putting in so much additional time
and work so we could all enjoy this big
and fun musical now here are some of the
behind-the-scenes secrets the stars
shared with us usually we start
rehearsals and pre records like a week
before we start shooting the episode so
that can be pretty hectic and then when
we're shooting it it's big groups of
people which usually means really long
days and trying to get everyone in sync
you know we've got some people who are
dancers or singers or whatever and we're
trying to get everyone to kind of find a
middle ground where we all feel really
comfortable and proud with the work that
we're doing it's the goal for the week I
think that this musical actually fits
the characters better than last year the
costumes are just insane I think they're
so much better this year - the songs are
really awesome the choreo is really
great especially some of the duet and
big group numbers it's just an elevation
of where we started who would like to go
next
I had vocal sessions out of get vocal
sessions before they had to record me
and everybody on the cast is here not
too often this season have we all been
together so that's been very exciting
gonna brought up with my blood arch here
just two single straight dudes doing
some data
yeah these musical episodes are huge
definitely the biggest episodes of the
season for sure in terms of the work
ethic and although the workload for the
actors and stuff it can be kind of
frustrating at times when you can't
really hit those notes but I mean that's
what the pitch correction is for I guess
a lot of it for me at least when I have
to have those high ones it can be hard
it's not like you show up on set and
learn the dance moves then it's all very
choreographed ahead of time and a lot of
work goes into it hours of preparation
and with actual dancers and the
choreographer whose name is Heather
ironically she's around here somewhere
what is your damage Heather and there
you have it thank you so much for tuning
in to this week's after-show for the
musical episode and be sure to check
back with me next week for our
Sweetwater secrets preview for episode
317 chapter 52 the master but for now
you know how this works please give this
video a like and then hit subscribe and
then shimmy your way down to the
comments to tell me your hisses and
kisses for the week what did you think
of all the relationship reconciliations
do you prefer carry the musical or
Heather's and were you a fan of Edgar
ever Nevers introduction I was what's
your damage River babes tell me in the
comments below and I'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]